when a country asks to be annexed the
answer isn't often no but in the case of
Moltar in 1955 when it asks to become a
formal part of the United Kingdom the
answer was just that but why why did in
Britain annex Malta despite it asking
for it so after World War Two Malta
remained a part of the British Empire as
a crown colony with some limited
self-government as the Cold War got off
the ground Britain was under immense
pressure from both the United States and
the USSR to decolonize and it wasn't
long before the UK asked what was to be
done with Malta since his position was
somewhat unique like many parts of the
British Empire motor cost money to
maintain whereas unlike many parts of
the British Empire motor was extremely
valuable strategically since his
position in the middle of the
Mediterranean meant that it made a prime
naval base in 1950 Malta held elections
and a man called Enrico Mitzi of the
Maltese Nationalist Party was elected
prime minister for three months before
he died and was succeeded by Giorgio
Borg Olivier whose primary policy was
advocating for motor to become an
independent nation the relationship
between Borg Olivier and the British
government was made more difficult when
he almost bankrupted the country in
three years by spending everything on
vote winning policies as such he asked
the British government for more money
whilst also demanding more autonomy
which shockingly strained relations so
at this point Malta is on the same
course as most other British colonies
that of discontent in independence yet
in 1955 Malta had an election which saw
it elect a new Prime Minister Dom in
Toth who proposed an alternative idea
allow motor to join the United Kingdom
the British government was very happy
with this idea because it meant that
they could keep this colony in America
in the USSR couldn't be angry because it
was democratic and so both sides quickly
began discussions on how to annex Moltar
into the UK the idea was that it would
become a constituent nation of the
United Kingdom and it would hold a
position similar to that of Northern
Ireland with its own local
representation as well as having three
members of parliament
now mint off wasn't being silly when he
proposed this since he knew that motor
was instrumental to British defense
policy and was fully aware of motors
financial problems if multiple part of
the United Kingdom the Maltese would
have access to British social programs
and they would have a small voice in
maintaining British defense spending on
the island in 1956 Malta held a
nationwide referendum on whether or not
it should join the United Kingdom which
yes won with 77 percent of the vote on
60 percent turnout so given that the
British
man wanted Malta to join the UK the
Maltese government wanted Malta to join
the UK and the public referendum had
affirmed the Maltese people's position
why didn't Malta actually join the
United Kingdom well there were several
reasons the first was that membership of
the United Kingdom was conditional on
Malta reining in its spending and
limiting the government there to only a
small budget deficit which meant off
rejected and soon afterwards resigned in
protest the second reason was that there
were many in the British government who
were concerned that multi join in the UK
would set a precedent for other Imperial
territories and the third reason was
over the course of the 1950s British
defense needs changed the motors
importance as a naval base declined
rapidly with these Britain's interest in
annexing the country faded away since it
was going to subsidize the island for
very little in return and so in the end
negotiations were called off from
Britain refused to annex Malta and in
1964 Malta gained its independence I
hope you enjoyed this episode and a
special thanks to all my patreon
supporters James vis annette marvin
castle a man of culture kelly moneymaker
danny Meloni Jon biscuit Rob Waterhouse
Mo Aaron the white James Castaneda
Gustav Swan Jordan long ray
Marcus Ozma spinning three plates
cooling Castleman filled oink-oink
Rashid Ali David Silverman easy Maggie
packs Kowski Spencer Lightfoot Winston K
word Robert Wetzel Lexi Schwinn Anthony
Beckett and Skye Chappell I think of it
as motors declaration of dependence